[Musique]
ah le brut c'est sofia du coup la
chanteront de préparer un bon type l'un
des plats préférés des patins à crime et
ben tu vois comme vous pouvez le voir je
suis en train de cuisiner avec aux pieds
parce que je suis sans les membres
supérieurs
[Musique]
marque de stylos et autres avant chaque
cours ex mènera jeune étoilé qui est
donné à l'enfant du chat cause
toujours des portables
regardez les gens me levais genre
existent et des pantalons l'élastique
sociale est tellement bien que rien des
travaux de groupe ces sociétés au plus
on s'habitue vite et en mairie en fait à
quel point c'est incroyable cette
affaire ont leurs limites
du coup l'aja de rentrée des cours et je
vais me préparer à manger moi j'ai
encore plus que lui a vécu une seconde
et maintenant ils touchent le sol
experts acteurs du coup ça dure dit
fâché
fait qu'au champ dollon d'urgence ça
veut dire pendant salle de bains j'en ai
une dans ma cuisine dans ma chambre
près partout je vois ça je pense pas que
les autres peuvent le faire comment ma
mère était enceinte je devais être
attendre de la trisomie 21 je devais ne
pas avoir deux membres inférieurs je
disais que je ne pouvais aussi nous
faire ne pas vivre quoi donc en fait
quand je suis né c'était plus un
soulagement qu'autre chose art
j'espère qu'à soit rejeter la vient de
rentrer en bts c'est tout frais et
j'avais j'étais comme ça cet été à
penser quand ça va se passer le regard
des gens y vont l'aider ou non parce que
souffrir à la une qualité mains des fois
aussi lorsqu'elle a besoin et ne livrera
pas été vite plus machos pelé l'autre ça
veut dire que je l' ai compris dès la
maternelle en fait que j'avais une
différence même web pour moi une section
je comprenais déjà
[Musique]
les genres les personnes extérieures ne
voulait pas que je vis ma famille
extérieur disent que c'est un danger moi
j'ai écouté que moi même je suis parti
voir un spécialiste un médecin agréé qui
m'a lui dirais de donner autorisation
quand j'ai su à la réponse du médecin à
ça m'a soulagé et puis ça
s'est laissé un professionnel qui sait
ce qui est le mieux pour ma sécurité il
a trouvé aucun danger donc du coup je
conduis une
voiture à boîte auto comme adaptation et
à l'accélérateur à gauche et les
commandes vocales par exemple le
clignotant à droite houlette les photos
jusqu'à la butte et
franchement sofia nous donne une vraie
leçon de vie c'est impressionnant le la
volonté cas là et je pense que si elle
continue à avoir cette volonté elle peut
devenir qui aiment faire absolument ce
qu'elle veut
il ya un an
sofia a créé son association soit maître
de ton handicap pour accompagner les
personnes à mobilité réduite moi j'ai
pas eu le sentiment d'avoir été bien
accompagné niveau papier niveau par
exemple est-ce que l'on peut l'inscrire
dans cette école et ses
niveaux aménagement
moi j'ai besoin d'aménagements de ses
sorties plus de 2 la tête de mon père
que la tête normalement des zéros
thérapeute g a proposé à plusieurs
reprises de porter des prothèses mais
j'ai jamais voulu tout simplement parce
que si je venais protée c'est plus moi
je serais plus moi même c'est pas ma
personnalité c'est devenu vraiment c'est
devenu un fait même sa à développer mon
caractère donc moi j'ai toujours refusé
et puis même si jean mais est-ce que je
vais savoir les utiliser en fait je me
sens bien comme ça et puis le jour en
jour je m'améliore